this is kind of wild we always have fake
alex jones on the show from time to time
you know and
we do it a lot we were mentioned on the
real alex jones
infowars network and the reason why wow
the recent uh article in the daily mail
attributed quotes
to the real alex jones but they were
actually quotes
that are fake alex jones did on the show
great the weird thing is the fake alex
jones on our show
was actually quoting the real alex jones
but the real alex jones called this
puppetgate
here you go there's so many falsehoods
in this article that i'm not going to go
over them all but
one of the other big glaring ones is
that a
puppet show that howard stern did in
december of last year
is me and they use quotes
in the article from the puppet show
saying that the puppet is alex jones i
am not the voice actor that
plays the alex jones character though he
is very talented
to take the words of a popsicle stick
puppet and to say it's me
is just next level disinformation it's
great to hear the real alex jones have
to deny what the puppet said but here's
the thing he's not a puppet yes
the daily mail quoted our alex jones
puppet
saying that there was hiv in the coveted
vaccine
and then it was actually a real quote
from alex jones here's the real alex's
quote
followed by our alex puppet tell you you
got to take these vaccines to live your
life you've got to take this to be able
to get on a plane
and then they tell you later by the way
this could kill your ass and it's got
hiv in it
it has hiv in it it has hiv in it it has
hiv in it
they want forced inoculation of the
gates vaccination which has
the hiv delivery system gene coding it
has hiv in it
it has hiv in it it has hiv in it this
is aids
2.0 eugenics for a post-human world
infowars.com
is the puppet wrong i don't know
i this is why it's puppetgate joining us
today
is alex jones puppet he wants to get on
the air and explain everything i don't
know what the hell he wants to explain
infowars.com
infowars.com
sometimes i have trouble following this
i don't know if it's the puppet i don't
know if it's you
i don't know what is going on explain
something to us
i will say it again i will make it as
clear as day i am not the puppet
i did not say the things that that
puppet said i never claimed there was
hiv in the vaccine i reported on
prestigious geneticists that say it's
confirmed by a weapon from the u.s to
chimera five virus and one they use the
mra they put the
hiv delivery systems with the gene guns
firing laboratories and molecular guns
where they stitch the pieces together
this is confirmed you know this 100
fouchy bezos soros
it's multi-level disinformation
infowars.com
infowars.com so you know it's with you
you're always so
angry that i don't know when you're
really angry are you really angry
i am at listen to go by the words of a
popsicle stick
puppet and print them as fact is so
disingenuous and horrible and
hold on one second howard the dr fouchy
puppet is here and would like to say
something so we can let him speak
uh go ahead falchy puppet our vaccine
will
kill you for our humanity and kill
kophid hail satan
heal bill gates wow fouchy puppet why
doesn't that get printed in the daily
mail in prison as a fact
huh stern what'd you tell me well hey
you make a point and by the way
i love your fouchy puppet i thought it
was cute i did thank you very much
listen there are a lot of people calling
in for wars right now they are upset
about this
let's go to uh let's go to the phones
right now we got king of all reptilians
on the line uh go ahead king
hey yo alex man why don't you check
these
billions your connection's horrible
how many times do we have to go through
every time you call my show you call in
with the horrible connection
man okay okay okay okay okay alex hold
on hold on hold on
if you're using bluetooth don't call my
shirt this is what you sound like
bill gates
infowars.com this guy's been calling my
show since 20 years since i was on
kjfk989 in austin i like him
but he can't get his phone right i don't
get it i gotta tell you you have the
same problems i do
i'm so sorry you got quoted in the daily
mail uh by accident with the puppet but
you i think you've cleared up the issue
okay thank you
that's it listen i gotta go pish i gotta
go close out my radio show it's getting
late but
for our christian radio philly
affiliates please stay tuned the alex
jones wrap
up show is coming up right now and i'll
see everybody tomorrow
we'll listen to infowars.com
good morning everybody it's the alex
jones wrap up show covering everything
that happened on today's alex jones show
we'll also cover what's coming up on
jones thology today
later in the show stay tuned and we'll
be right back with
the alex jones wrap up show